Elevator floor buttons and coffee mug handles are both affordances and
signifiers, because they both signal that an
interaction can happen, and their physical characteristics allow
the interaction to take place. Also, traffic lights are indeed signifiers.
The lights themselves don't permit an interaction between an object and an
agent. But, by cultural convention, they
do signify that certain actions should and
can take place. The incorrect statement here is statement C.
The word pull on a door does not permit action between an object and an actor,
and so it's not an affordance. The sign does, however, signify
that the door should be operated. We'll talk more about signifiers next.